T
WHAT'S GOING ON IN ANOTHER TOWN
BY AN OCEAN.
THAT IS LOS ANGELES.
WE SHOWED YOU A COUPLE OF DAYS
AGO THE IMAGES OF THE BURGLARS
OR ROBBERS BECAUSE THEY HAD
SLEDGE HAMMERS THEY KNOCKED OUT
THE PLATE GLASS WINDOW AT
BEVERLY HILLS JEWELRY STORE
RIGHT THERE.
THEY STOLE BETWEEN 3 AND $5,000
WORTH OF EXPENSIVE JEWELRY.
>> Ainsley: IN THE MIDDLE OF
DAYLIGHT.
>> Steve: ABSOLUTELY.
BY THE TIME THE OWNER CAME OUT,
THE OWNER WAS COMING OUT WITH
HIS GUN, THEY HAD ALREADY JUMPED
INTO A STOLEN CAR.
THIS IS SUCH A PROBLEM.
THINK ABOUT IT, L.A. IS A VERY
SHOWY TOWN.
IF YOU HAVE A NICE ROLEX WATCH
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT YOU ARE
GOING TO WEAR IT MAYBE YOU
SHOULDN'T BECAUSE THE COPS SAY
YOU WILL BE A TARGET.
>> Ainsley: LOOK AT THIS VIDEO,
WE WALK BY JEWELRY STORES AFTER
THEY CLOSE.
THEY TAKE OUT ALL THE JEWELRY
RIGHT BEHIND US IS THE -- THEY
EMPTY THE CASES.
THEY EMPTY THE WINDOWS BECAUSE
THEY DON'T EXPECT SOMEONE TO DO
THIS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DAYLIGHT.
>> Brian: THE LAPD IS HAMSTRUNG
BY IDIOTIC MAYOR, I GUESS THEY
BELIEVE IN REDISTRIBUTION OF
WEALTH.
SAYS THIS OVER THE LAST YEAR
THERE HAS BEEN A MARKED INCREASE
OF ARMED ROBBERIES INVOLVING
VICTIMS WEARING EXPENSIVE
JEWELRY.
HERE IS A WARNING TO THEM.
IF IT'S VISIBLE, IT CAN BE A
TARGET.
YOU KNOW THAT EXPENSIVE JEWELRY,
LEAVE IT WHERE IT BELONGS IN THE
SAFE IN YOUR HOUSE THAT'S WHY
YOU BOUGHT IT YOU DON'T WANT TO
BE ABLE TO WEAR IT AND HAVE
SOMEONE STEAL IT FROM YOU.
>> Ainsley: ROBBERIES UP 18%.
ROBBERIES WITH A FIREARM ARE UP
44% IN THAT AREA.
IF YOU READ THE ARTICLE, THIS
SAYS THE VICTIMS ARE BEING
TARGETED BASED ON HIGH END
JEWELRY AND HIGH END CARS.
THEY WILL FOLLOW THESE VICTIMS
HOME AND TARGET THEM.
ONE VICTIM WAS PISTOL WHIPPED
AND THE OTHER HAD THEIR ROM
ELECTION AND THEIR PHONES STOLEN
AT GUNPOINT.
TALKS ABOUT HOW ANOTHER ONE
BROKE-TALKS ABOUT THE JEWELRY
STORE.
SOMEONE WAS DRIVING AN EXPENSIVE
CAR AND THEY FOLLOWED THAT
PERSON HOME AND STOLE $3,600.
>> Steve: SO THE LAPD NOW HAS A
FOLLOW HOME UNIT TO FOLLOW SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
FOLLOWING SOME OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO TRY TO HIT SOMEBODY
OVER THE HEAD TO STEAL THEIR --
>> Brian: THE WAY IT'S WORKING
ORGANIZED CRIME HIRING GUYS TO
SMASH THE WINDOWS AND GET THE
STUFF AND SELL IT ON ANY SITE
THEY WANT.
CRIME IS OKAY IN LOS ANGELES.
FINALLY IN NEW YORK THEY ARE
WISING UP AND PROSECUTING
EVERYTHING EVEN PEOPLE JUMP IN
THE TURN STYLES.
THAT'S THE NEW MESSAGE,
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL GET THE
MESSAGE BECAUSE THEY ARE
DESTROYING THAT STATE.
>> Ainsley: YOU GREW UP HERE.
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE GROWING UP
MY PARENTS ALWAYS SAID IF YOU GO
TO NEW YORK DON'T WEAR ANY
JEWELRY.
>> Steve: PUT YOUR MONEY IN A
MONEY SOCK.
>> Ainsley: ZIPPER SO THEY CAN'T
REACH IN THERE NOW WE ARE BANG
TO THAT IN L.A.
>> Brian: TRAVEL WITH THE